Do you choose love or money? Oh my goodness.
Um.
Finding love, especially during this time can be pretty tough.
Not knowing someone's intentions is pretty scary. Right? So for today's episode,
we asked Taylor to choose between love or money.
What do you think she'll choose? That's fine.
Welcome.
Hello everybody. And hello to bachelorette. Number one. How are you feeling?
You're feeling excited. You're feeling nervous.
Very fine. Before I started seeing all the faces and now my heart is like.
I want to get to know you a little bit. Right?
And I'm sure all these guys want to get to know you too.
Yeah. So I'm model part-time and then I'm also in grad school for psychology,
because I want to be a therapist. What's a way to your heart.
I'm really emotional.
So somebody who just has a lot of like emotional intelligence or is emotionally
tune, that's really attractive for Bella.
Chance to stand out. I'm going to have you guys introduce yourselves,
give us something interesting. That'll make you stand up.
Give us your elevator pitch
Advance, um, into per core, trying new things, traveling to new places at once,
bought a pick off of Craigslist. And I lost it in my dorm room over the radio.
And I don't always, if you want to go to a music festival, I'm all game.
If you want to rewatch Harry Potter again, I'm also all game.
[inaudible] like a serenade. You at your house, electric a lot.
I'm from England. And my fun fact is that I died in the past.
I died in the past. If you need someone to take your breath away on your man,
I'm a personal trainer. So if you ever want to get a workout in,
we could do that. I'm living my lifelong dreams and meteorologists.
So if you ever need to know, and there's a 30% chance started raining,
I mean to photography and modeling as well.
So hopefully we can get a shoot together. I love skateboarding.
I love doing film photography as well. I enjoy dancing, going to the club.
Really liked the photography so I can definitely picture us together.
I'm British. I'm a creditor. Perfect. You don't want the real camera.
I happen to love therapist and models. So I'm the perfect guide for you.
I'm also a Scorpio. You mentioned your emotional Scorpios. The water's fine.
And we're known to be emotional. Plant-based cook, chill,
laid back guy and a family oriented. I give a ride.
Most of the vehicles that either have wheels or slide.
So I'm a slide to your BMS. After this.
I hope a college degree is no requirement for you because I actually dropped out
of college. Don't eliminate me.
Well, I'm pretty cringy. I don't know if you can say already, but.
SoundCloud artists or whatever. I like to go camping. Uh,
I'm into photography, um, instructor,
constructor and actor stand up hiking. I cook a lot. I'm actually going to ask.
You if you could close your eyes real quick and you can open that. And well,
here I am. I'm the sign that you were looking for.
That was really good.
Up until now. It was all fun and games. It was all laughter. However,
I am going to put the responsibility on you of eliminating
down to 10 people right off the bat. Half of them have to go home.
Um, I'm just going to list them. I don't even want to say why.
Cause I'm so scared, but know that I love you. Okay. Number five.
Number seven number. Where am I at? I don't know where I'm at.
Oh my God. Don't even look at me. Five, five more, five more
number,
number six.
To the 10. They made her. Give yourself a Pat on the back. Give yourself a hand.
Oh my gosh. Certainly laugh is not cute.
If you can make her ugly cackle, you know, she likes you. Okay.
So bachelorette number one,
I'm going to offer you a proposition I have with me a hundred dollars right now.
If you choose to take this $200, you can go home,
call it a day and relax by yourself. A nice meal.
Or you can continue on to the next round with these 10 lovely gentlemen.
So bachelorette number one. Do you choose?
Where am I choosing this?
Well, no hesitation right off the bat. Alrighty.
Y'all we are moving on to stage number two.
Number two is the special skills slash talent portion.
So bachelorette number one.
What's the interesting fact there like a special skill that yeah.
I like to lift the most I've ever squatted is 300 pounds.
My gosh, I'm ready to get some lift.
Okay. Okay. Now love her toes. Yeah. Watch out Bella. Watch out.
I'm going to give each of you 30 seconds to showcase the talent.
Sorry. That would just, you know, do a self portrait.
I don't know. It just took me three days where you mentioned you love lifting.
So that's why I got my lifting belt with me. Ready?
Do you have like a YouTube channel and stuff like that?
Where I cook and share with me.
That cinnamon bun was a little too sensual and made me unbuttoned one,
one boat.
And I made this grilled cheese like an hour ago. So it's kind of Lindsey,
but I'm going to pull it just to see if the cheese those out. Okay.
So no that's kind of awkward.
Which one are you guys was the personal trainer. I'm calling them out.
I'm the personal trainer. What you got? Show me.
Well more pushups than the personal trainer guy.
I love how competitive guys get. Oh, you do pushups or you do push push go
two, three, four, five
Time. We'll give you 43 for the benefit of doubt.
Impressive 18 with a hoodie on to number 12.
Are you up for the pushup challenge? I'm going to do something a little better.
So I have a hundred pound dumbbell right now. I could curl it. I could lift it.
You just crawled a hundred pounds. That's like.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Well, number nine was moving his fingers. I can do something with my tongue
also. Um, uh, 18 did pushups. Great. Um.
Okay. All right, Bruce. Please
clap your hands.
You guys are very talented, but personally I don't have a special talent.
I really don't. The only thing special is the way I would treat you.
You just seem to have lines in your pocket. So hit bachelor, red,
number one with one of your finest lights.
I don't know what you would do here. I don't know what you're doing here. If ah,
how does it go? I forgot how it goes. Okay. I got it. I got it. I got it.
What you're doing here. Okay. I don't understand what you're doing here.
Who's the guardian Kevin.
All right. So bachelor number one, instead of eliminating,
I want you to pick your top five.
I probably have to say something about his demeanor is just like,
I'm just comfortable with contestant. Number 11.
I really like his charisma contested.
Number four was all the classes and stuff. I was like, Oh, snap, number 13.
Contested that moves on. Who is it going to be?
I the fact that he's a trainer. Well, thank you guys. Best of luck out there.
All right. So congratulations to the five of you. Let's give it up.
Bachelorette. Number one. Uh let's let's chat.
I know I offered you like $200. I felt like that wasn't enough. Right?
And these guys seem pretty great, but you know what? Offer sounds great. 300.
I mean it does sound kind of nice. You can take this 300, call it a day.
Go have some fun or we can continue on to the next stage with these five
gentlemen. So do you choose love?
Wow.
Okay. Some of, some of y'all are like sitting there,
like I would have taken the money. Shoot. I don't know for sure.
I don't know. I don't know what you see in these guys.
All five of you will have a chance to do an activity that bachelor,
bachelorette number one enjoys of to her picking.
And like I said, I'm really emotional.
I want to see how passionate you guys can get.
So I want you to reenact like a scene.
If somebody would like shoot you or like stab you. And like,
I want sort to like reenact, like the sub guy.
That is so original. How would you die if you were the star of your own?
Y why?
I have Oh, 650 stones. Yeah.
You think so, but I'm iron man. And then the golden builds up until the kids.
I love them. I'll see you on the other side.
I'll have the rest of your money soon. Just put the gun down here.
I have a part of it. Now.
I'll give you a thing. Is that okay? Let's say you just ate a poisonous steak.
I like the flip.
Oh my I'm sorry. I have to be this way. Casey,
shoot a gun real quick.
What? You loved me.
You cheated on me. My own brother
always love you forever.
That was a long day for someone that just got shot into heart.
You had a monologue, right? Sure.
Number one, we have to eliminate three people.
Literally counting. Okay. I can do this.
The first person and willing to eliminate
13. Oh my gosh. Okay.
Number 12 said that I cheat on him with his brother.
The acting got to use to real.
Do that.
Contestant number four and number 11, give it up. Congrats guys.
Number one. I got it. I got some more money.
Clearly, right? For all the effort and time that you've been putting in.
$500.
Number 11 is like, Oh shoot. You might want to take that girl. I don't know.
He was, I think he would understand. Number four. Not so much.
Come on guys. She's emotion. You guys got to sit for her. You got to be like,
no, I'm worth way more than the 500 baby girl. You either take this 500,
go travel somewhere.
If it's safe or you move on and you pick a lucky
guy, bachelorette, number one,
do you choose love?
Um,
my integrity keeps telling me.
Love. Wow. I am. That's getting me emotional, emotional.
Person. I mean that you really are.
You really are. I love that. Okay.
[Inaudible].
So each of you guys will have a one-on-one time to talk to our lovely bachelor,
right? And get to know each other on a more personal and deeper.
Basic.
How's it gone? Hi, isn't this weird?
I know this is so weird. I'm so nervous.
First and foremost, I'm super excited. You're drop dead. Gorgeous.
I love you're a whole goat to your look.
Um, I didn't think I'll make this far as far as keeping me
standing. So a little bit about myself. I'm Chinese. I'm from China.
Went to Brazil when I was five years old. I came to the us when I was 17.
I speak Portuguese, um, English and Mandarin. Where are you?
I'm in Chino, California.
Like 40 minutes away from where I'm at.
Tell me a little bit for yourself right now.
I'm doing a whole zoom universities tuition because of the pandemic I like to
sing. Um, I'm passionate about modeling. I am religious. Um,
I don't know if they're religious. Are you religious at all?
What kind of religion? I'm Christian.
And then I also consider myself spiritual.
I was raised Catholic. I'm actually from a TJ, Mexico,
just kind of something that my parents raised me off as I was able to venture
out for myself and see what kind of stuff is out there. And I, you know,
I started going to a Christian Church.
So now religion has become a huge part of my life. You know?
Beautiful. No I'm Christian. So
I would identify also a spiritual because I believe in like crystals and like
meditation and all that.
That's something that I've kind of been trying to like venture out and learn
more about it. Cause sometimes just the stress for the world is this.
I mean, I'm happy to teach you. I'm learning too. So don't think.
You went from 20 guys and you narrow down to two.
And he's gracious. I'm a sucker for a smile. They both have beautiful smiles.
Oh they do. Oh, bachelor, number one.
This is the moment where you have to choose.
Um, religion is something that's super important to me.
So I'm going to have to eliminate and tested them.
It's all good. Thank you so much.
Number 11. Why don't you look at that?
I can't believe this is what Jews are made of.
So congrats to you too. If only that were at the end, right?
If only there was more, you know what I mean? Come on guys.
I'm going to talk to each of you individually and I'm going to offer a
proposition just to make things a little more complicated.
I'm going to give you more choices.
So I'm going to present you with three options so you can either choose love or
money. If both of you choose love, then you get to split the 500,
get two 50 each and go on a second date. It's a win-win
however, if one of you chooses love, but one of you chooses money.
The person that chooses money,
cash it out all 500 and the other person goes home brokenhearted.
But if both of you guys get greedy and try to choose money,
you guys both go home with nothing.
She's carefully. Option three. Sounds like complete duty. Um, I dunno,
man.
We chose love every single round,
but go with what you think is best love or money. Is this, this,
this guy worth the love.
Honestly, for me, I just, I just, she chose money, huh?
Hey, we're about to find out.
Hi guys.
Hello?
That was the most nervous. Hi, I've heard from both of y'all. All right,
everyone. Good? Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Loud and clear.
Three, two.
[Inaudible].
Uh, it was easy too easy of a question to ask me. I had the feeling.
I felt that connection. I was like, it's a no brainer, man. Love is,
is the way to go. Love, heals all things. That's it.
It was the only, it was the only reasonable choice period.
Drops mic. Oh my gosh. I literally, my cheeks hurt from smiling.
I was like, man, they're going to offer me like a thousand dollars. If I.
Did what? That I've changed your answer. Hell.
No, you could have said a million.
Oh, a million. Okay. All right.
All right guys. Well, I've done my job. That's it for me.
I'm a leave you two lovebirds and thank you bachelorette for choosing love.
At the end of the day, over the moon with the outcome,
I was very interested in her. I was hoping she picked me from the start.
I wrote her with the, with, uh, my juggling skills. I think it's what.
Even if you would have chose money,
I think I would have still been happy with my decision.
I just think love is a beautiful thing.
And I know I sound super cliche and super cheesy, but keep trying,
keep your heart open and know that living locally.